thank you oh thank you thank you studio
audience
greetings big day here at HBO for us
greetings to our new viewers at HBO max
yes and of course our regular viewers at
HBO and all you cheap bastards who wait
to watch us on YouTube but look it's
it's like what is it our eighth show
here from the home and look it's
frustrating but I am very happy that we
are still able to do the kind of show we
do here and put it on I mean it's
nothing sadder than watching The Real
Housewives try to throw wine at each
other over zoom that is but we had a big
holiday weekend Memorial Day and it's
good not wait to get out there boy the
gloves were off and then when the masks
came off and eventually the pants did
you see the like the Lake of the Ozarks
and the Jersey Shore my home state you
know people I got to say Americans it
proved once again Americans they want to
do the right thing but if someone taps a
keg and cranks up the Leonard Skynyrd
all bets are off
[Applause]
tell conservatives even conservatives a
little worried about this we still need
to take precautions but like Sean
Hannity this week was almost begging
people to wear the face masks I guess he
finally has realized that the Venn
diagram of most vulnerable Americans and
Fox News viewers it's a circle
but you can't blame people for wanting
to get out there the Census Bureau is
now reporting that a third of Americans
are showing signs of anxiety and
clinical depression and they've gained
weight a third of Americans are now half
of Americans yeah we got to get in shape
again our own governor Gavin Newsom here
in California said he will know in a
week if the gyms can reopen and I hope
that is the case because Californians we
miss our gyms not not to work out so
much the staring at yourself in the
mirror party that's and they say there's
going to be a meat shortage which I
think it's already here because today I
saw a lady Gaga wearing a dress that was
past its expiration date so by the way
that joke is past its expiration what
the last time Lady gaga anyway things
are I think getting back to normal and
by normal I mean that we are again
witnessing ugly racial incidents there
was horrible death in Minneapolis and
also in Central Park in New York a black
man a birdwatcher told a white woman
walking her dog who was supposed to be
on a leash that she had to put the dog
on the leash and she called the cops on
him and it turns out this woman the
white woman is a Democrat who donated to
Obama yet on the memo on she wrote take
my money just don't hurt me
another sign that we are returning to
normal is that Trump is golfing again
yes golfing and he assures everybody
yes I'm golfing but I am laser-focused
not none of course on the virus on
stopping Joe Scarborough from killing
again did you see that he wants Joe
Scarborough this is in crave kind of
what he thinks Joe Scarborough killed
somebody in the 90s and now Trump wants
forensic geniuses to investigate on a
new show called CSI brain fart
[Applause]
and Trump is furious get this at Twitter
because Twitter started fact-checking
his twins oh my god fact that that
doesn't sit well with him and this is so
weird because his tweets this is a
favorite thing to write on for Donald
Trump Twitter it's like watching a
pervert argue with a bathroom wall but
you know what can't blame it on the
hydroxychloroquine he said Donald Trump
has said he has quit taking now
hydroxychloroquine he has pronounced
himself completely cured of mad cow
disease but no word on whether he's
going to give up the idea to imbibe
household disinfectants I tell you
something his fans haven't pine-sol now
comes in prescription strength
you